poor weather is delaying the effort to
recover three renowned climbers missing
in the Canadian Rockies Jess Ross Kelly
David Lama and Hans York our are part of
an elite athletic team for the outdoor
apparel giant The North Face rescuers
say all three men are presumed dead
after being caught in an avalanche the
trio was climbing or was attempting to
climb house peak in Alberta's Banff
National Park
Ross Kelly's father and sister spoke
with us following the tragedy David beg
know is here with the interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning
David very sad story it is John you know
the apparently this Avalanche was big
enough to wipe out a small building or
even cover a car pretty they say it was
a three on a scale of five the three
athletes set out on Monday to tackle one
of the most challenging climbs in the
Canadian Rockies Jess Ross Kelly's
family says he always checks in with
them to let him know he's safe but on
Tuesday they had not heard from him and
that's when Jess's father decided to
call authorities sometimes I always feel
over my head there's plenty of times
where I'm cold hungry tired and you got
another 10 12 hours ago
National Geographic calls Jess Ross
Kelly one of the most accomplished
climbers of his generation he was 20
years old back in 2003 when he became
the youngest person to summit Mount
Everest I asked him if he wanted to go
to Everest and of course he did Jess his
father is climbing pioneer John Ross
Kelly he says his son had never scaled
house peak when he set out to tackle the
nearly 11,000 foot summit with two other
professional Mountaineers David Lama and
Hans jörg our they had all done climbs
more difficult than this
it's just that they like the the looks
of this route that route up house peak
is the so-called m16 it's a roughly
4,000 foot ascent up vertical ice and
rock Ross Kelly says it's a challenge
for only the most extreme climbers this
route is has some of the most difficult
climbing that you can find anywhere in
the world
Ross Kelly says the three men wanted to
complete their climb by Tuesday night
but by Thursday Canada's now
no Parks Agency said the three climbers
were presumed dead and that's because
helicopter crews spotted signs of
multiple avalanches and debris that
contained climbing equipment all three
of them were really knowledgeable about
avalanche conditions and dangers he
loves to hear the people around him so
deeply
Jordan Ross Kelly is Jess's sister she
says her brother had a great sense of
humor and an enormous heart we've had
interest an outpouring of people who
care for and he has a beautiful wife who
adores him as well and so we're we're
with her and doing the best we can you
know it's unclear exactly when the
Avalanche occurred John Ross Kelly says
bad weather is keeping the search and
rescue teams from accessing that field
of debris where they avalanche happened
the family says they're planning to ski
to the area tomorrow in hopes of helping
to find the victim so difficult they
can't get there at this point I could
see why they want to be involved in the
search you know absolutely we just want
to answer for sure thank you David